- What's up believe nation, happy weekend.
I'm excited because I'm
launching a new series
to talk to you about how to get
one million YouTube subscribers.
At least, I think I'm going
to launch a new series.
Today's the first day
and I want your feedback
to see if I should continue
this series or not.
Earlier this year, I hit
half a million subscribers.
It was an awesome day.
We had a live hangout
as I crossed the mark,
it was a ton of fun and energy.
Nine, ninety, nine,
ninety, nine, nine, nine,
Oh, you trollers, ninety
eight, come on you guys.
Oh, there it is!!!
Guys, 500K that was intense.
I lost my voice.
I have more interviews
tonight, this is crazy.
And I'm hoping that this
year I will hit one million,
at least that is my goal.
I am on the path to do it
and I thought I would share,
once a month, my strategies,
answer your questions,
help you build a full-time
income off of YouTube.
Get your channel to even bigger heights,
reaching more people,
having a bigger impact.
As well as sharing my tips and strategies,
I would dissect my growth
versus another YouTube creator
and try to understand
where the differences lie
and give you the strategies
and the how to grow quickly.
Today I'm going to look at
myself versus Erik Thomas,
ET the Hip Hip Preacher and
let's see how we're doing.
I love using a tool called Social Blade.
You can check it out, socialblade.com
to compare how I'm doing
versus other creators
and look at my growth daily.
It can be addictive to
see how well you're doing.
Here is my graph versus
Eric for the past year.
Let me be clear here, this is
what was interesting for me.
I love Eric.
It would be an honor to
have him on my channel.
It would be an honor to share
the stage with him at an event.
I consider Eric to be one of
the greatest speakers of our generation.
He's the new Les Brown for
me and I love Les Brown.
Young Les Brown was, is the guy
that I look up to most
in the speaking industry.
So, I think Eric is a way
better speaker than I am,
at this moment, and I have
a huge amount of respect
for what he's doing and the
lives that he has changed.
If you look at our YouTube channels,
you'll see that my
videos are crossing his,
in terms of subscribers, and
we recently just passed him.
What's the difference?
Looking at our Social Blade results,
you see my line going
up and you see his line
still going up, but not as fast.
Let's look at each number.
If you look at the bottom part there,
I'm at 569,000 subscribers,
he's at 555, okay.
That's where we're at when
I'm filming this video.
Our video views are kind of close.
I'm at 74 and a bit, he's at 58 and a bit,
so not that big a difference
between where we're ranking,
and our users were created
about the same time.
I was 2008, in November,
he was 2008, in December.
The big number that
separates me from Eric,
is the number of videos uploaded,
I'm at 3.7 thousand videos
uploaded on my channel, he's at 553.
If we back up, if we
back up and think about
what I just said about
Eric being a great speaker
and one of the best
speakers of our generation,
how much respect that I have for him.
Why am I able to pass is because
I'm uploading more content.
That's part of the YouTube algorithm.
They want to see regular,
consistent content.
Now you don't want to
just throw up crap, right.
You don't want to just throw
anything up there just to get it
because people have to watch it.
You have to put something out there
that is good enough people want to watch,
but I'm also believing that
the quantity leads to the quality.
That by practicing, that
by making more videos,
by honing your skills,
you'll get better and better
and better and better
and better each time.
While I only have 3 point,
only, have 3.7 thousand videos
uploaded, I've done another 500 to 1,000
that have never made it public.
Just from me practicing and practicing
and practicing and practicing.
It helps me get better, but
for the YouTube algorithm,
they want to see lots of content.
So I would be looking at,
at least, once a week.
I think once a week now is not even
the bare minimum any more.
I mean, they want to really see you get
to multiple times per
week, if not daily content.
Now, I'm a bit of a strange animal,
we're at three videos, at least, per day
and that's what's helping
drive a lot of the growth.
So, I think a lot of people pay attention
to the wrong metric,
where they're looking at
how many views per video
and it's the wrong metric to look at
because what I care about is overall views
and overall subscribers.
I care about how many people
is the message reaching net,
not on a per video basis
and you should too.
If you're comparing how many views I get
on an average video, compared to someone
who's uploading once a month,
I might lose that game
and I'm okay with it.
That's the small game,
that's the nothing game.
Go to Social Blade and
compare my channel to them
and you'll see massive
growth against almost anybody
on views and on subscribers
because of the upload frequency.
I would challenge you, if
you're posting once a month
on your YouTube channel, to
get it to at least once a week
and if you're once a week to get it
to at least a couple times a week
and if you're a couple
times a week, daily.
If this is important to
you, this is something
that you really want to do,
you have to find the time for it.
You have to post daily, good content.
Good!
Something you're proud of,
not just mailing it in,
it's got to be good, solid stuff.
Then you'll be able to
beat people, beat people,
cross over them, have more impact, growth,
subscribers, views, than people
who may be better than you
because you understand the
algorithm more than they do.
So that's my tip of the day, of the week,
of the month, I guess, and that's how
we've been able to pass
Eric on his channel.
If he were to post daily content as well,
he would start crushing me,
so I hope that doesn't happen.
I do think of it as a gift
of all the content that he does create.
Here's my question.
I'm thinking about creating this series.
I want to continue it and
I want it to be interactive
and I want to answer
your questions, as well.
If I'm doing a part two, next month,
what I want to know is,
what are some of your key
YouTube questions, concerns,
about growing a channel, about
turning it into a business,
anything you have, I want
you to leave that question
in the comment below and maybe next month,
if I do this again, I'll
answer your question
to help give you some
more guidance, advice
and help you have a
bigger impact on YouTube.
So let me know what you
guys think of the series .
Should we keep it?
Should we kill it and do something else?
Leave it in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.